welcome back everybody a major
development in ohio's largest ever
murder investigation
one of the four people charged in the
pike county massacre admits he
and his family committed the crimes and
jeannette levy's back with the latest in
this saga and jeanette
jesse for many years jake wagner and
members of his family have vehemently
denied
any involvement in the rodent and gilly
murders but now
that has changed yes your honor
i agree to what the state has provided
and i'm deeply and very sorry on the
fifth anniversary of the rhoden and
gilley murders
jake wagner stood in a pike county
courtroom and admitted he and his family
killed the eight family members
including the mother of his child hannah
mayrden
what plead you wish to get her in count
seven to the charge of aggravated murder
of hannah
wagner appeared to tear up when hannah
may's name was mentioned
prosecutors say wagner his mother angela
father billy and older brother george
wanted full custody of the little
girl hannah and jake shared he recently
confessed to state
investigators after years of denying
involvement
what he told us led us to discover some
evidence that had yet to be recovered
specifically the weapons that were used
in these offenses
along with vehicles that were used
during these offenses including one that
was bought specifically to use the night
of the homicide
wagner and his family were indicted in
november 2018
after a two and a half year
investigation that included pleas from
geneva rhoden the matriarch of the
family
i'd just like to say from my mother's
heart
that i hurt so bad inside
from the day that i found out at the
start of the investigation there were
few leads
then investigators attention turned to
the wagners a year after the murders
this was cold cold cold blood i mean
this was calculated
planned out ohio governor mike dewine
was the attorney general when the
murders happened
that day he promised the rodents the
case would be solved
family's been through hell while today
i'm sure was a very gratifying day it
couldn't have been easy day
they've got to be leaving here just
totally exhausted and you know
emotionally spent
but these are tough people these are
strong people
and as part of the plea agreement jake
wagner has actually agreed to testify
against his mother his father and his
older brother
and the death penalty as part of the
plea agreement has been taken off of the
table
for all of them jesse wow all right
thanks and jeanette let's bring back in
our panel uh professor so
wagner pleads guilty the death penalty
is taken
off the table apparently for all them is
that justice
i guess it depends on your view of
whether the death penalty is an
appropriate penalty at any point
i will say it may be justice for the
family because it could possibly save
them
the pain of a very long trial with all
types of testimony that would be
wildly uncomfortable for them so it very
well might be
you know terry how do you think jake
wagner's guilty plea
is going to affect the cases against his
other family members
you talk about family drama my gosh
absolutely
you know i think this is really
obviously going to help the prosecution
because
they initially were going off in
tangents now they have someone
who is cooperating they have someone who
can give them specific
evidence they don't have to worry about
getting this conviction because
clearly he is talking and he is going to
confess as far as the others are
concerned so
i think it's going to save the state
money i think it's going to save
both families obviously time to deal
with this issue
and it's going to help the community
because for many years people have been
wondering
what is going to happen in this case it
was one of the
most horrific crimes i think anyone has
seen this was
a huge massacre and to have everything
solved now i think is really going to
help all around
and i know you've been following this
case and the governor said
this was well planned what do we know
about that and also
why did wagner decide to confess
well first of all part of the reason the
governor says it was so well planned was
because
the wagners apparently according to jake
and according to the
state agents had hacked into the
facebook accounts
of some of the rodents and actually had
were monitoring them
in their homes through surveillance
cameras so this was
very well planned from the aspect that
hannah rhoden
in a tech in a facebook message months
prior to the murders
said to somebody to get my child they're
going to have to kill me first
and then after that the governor and the
state agents say
that wagner said they began to plan the
murders they bought
bullets they bought shoes they bought
guns they bought vehicles
so and wagner says he found god
that is why he confessed to the murders
wow classic okay this case
just keeps on coming all right coming up
on long crime daily the new supreme
court ruling
making it easier to sentence juveniles
to spend their lives
in prison plus the trial of the only
officer charged in the
brianna taylor case now delayed we'll
tell you why
coming up